I think I'd like to talk to myself in the future.
Yes, that's something that I'll do.
I wonder what my past is up to.
Hi, Jeremiah.
Hello, Jeremiah.
You look different.
Do I?
Yes.
I'm 12 years old.
How are you?
How old are you?
26.
Ah, well you look older.
Thanks.
Yes.
It goes to show how much things have changed, yes.
Yes, I suppose so.
Ah, yes.
Well, me of the future?
Well, so how are things?
Things are okay, working at a general store.
Trying out what you expected to be doing at this age...
...but hope that you hadn't really given it much thought at all.
As far as I can see, is Molly still alive?
The dog Molly?
No, she would be about 30 years old if she were still alive.
Well yes, okay.
Yes, and what about Leon?
The cat got him.
Very interesting.
Now, don't you realize that you're kind of messing up time?
Excuse me?
Do you still like Doctor Who?
Yeah.
Yes, good.
I like it.
I know.
Anyway, well I guess that's all I want to ask of you.
Well, thank you.
I see a resemblance.